Used all around the table. How many people do you think to see that? Did you see
the weird. finally finished.
By Chris and Andrew. Don't you mean by Andrew and Chris? A lot more people know
who I am. Yeah, but I have more online friends. But my friends leave more
comments. Guys, guys.
We can settle this, with statistics. Everyday we have to make decisions. At the
grocery store when we look at ingredients, when we're choosing products to buy,
and when we need to decide who's more popular online. There's data all around
us, and we're going to show you how to use this data. But will I need to know a
lot of math? This class is for everyone. You only need a basic understanding of
00:00:41,985 --> 00:00:00,000
fractions, decimals, and percentages. Enroll now.